接下来我来给大家讲一下如何去装配我们Triton Ascend的环境
首先第一步我们都是要安装我们的看
也就是之前在上一章提到过的一个计算架构
我们首先在那个Triton Ascend的开源仓
首页的README里边就有这个安装指南的链接
在里面有明确的写我们需要哪个版本的看
看呢我们就可以直接在声通的官网上获取
我们在顶部导航这一栏我们只要点击这个看
就可以导航到它的看的首页
然后我们在这个下载上面点开这个社区版
就能打开我们这个CANN软件包的下载页面
在这个下载页面里呢我们要选择我们指定的软件版本
然后选择我们是CPU架构什么
就是x86还有aarch64
然后我们就下载这个RUN的这个软件包就行
我们跑Triton的话至少需要下边这两个
一个是这个Toolkit
还有就是这个Kernels
然后Kernels这边要注意一下
它有这个有个硬件型号的这个选择我们要选对
然后我们就根据我们的这个CPU架构还有我们的硬件型号
就可以下载我们需要的两个软件包
Kernels的安装教程也放在了我们的升能社区上
大家第一步还是点开我们Kernels的首页
在这里面就可以找到我们的社区版文档
这个文档里面呢
不只是我们Kernels的安装教程
还包括了Kernels里边的各个组件的使用文档
这里面呢我们就先选择我们的安装的版本
然后在里面就可以点开我们的环境准备这块的内容
在安装的时候呢我们会先选择我们的安装场景
包括了安装方式
操作系统
还有业务场景这些信息
然后就可以在左边观看我们的安装文档
在这里面呢就包括了Toolkit
还有Kernel的安装命令
以及他们安装命令中各个选项的解释
大家要注意如果我们的升能环境是第一次使用
也就是说如果我们没有安装好
它的固件和驱动
那我们固件和驱动也需要我们手动来进行安装
这两个工具的安装教程也是在这块
安装完看之后
我们就可以安装我们的Triton Ascend
而我们Triton Ascend呢有两种安装方式
一种是直接通过wheel包来进行一个快速安装
如果我们只是用Triton Ascend来做我们的算子开发
那就可以用这种快速安装的方式
还有一种方式就是通过源码构建
因为我们Triton Ascend已经开源了
所以大家可以在上面去做一些创新
还有一些新功能的开发
那如果我们改造了圆码
就需要我们用源码构建的方式来安装我们的Triton Ascend
首先讲一下快速安装的方式
也就是pip install
如果我们不是root用户的话
我们可以先用类似于conda的这种方法去封装一个独立的环境
或者说我们在pip install的时候加上--user这个选项
首先我们对python上有明确的版本要求
必须是在python3.9到3.11之间的这几个版本
然后就是我们要按照前两页的方法去下载并且安装我们的软件包
但是要注意在安装这个看之后呢
必须要source我们CANN的里面的环境设置脚本
去配置好我们的环境变量
这样我们的CANN才会生效
再后面就是安装我们的python依赖库
那边我们有完整的命令
里面描述了我们需要的所有库还有对应的版本
不过随着我们的Triton Ascend的版本的迭代
这些依赖库的版本需求也会发生对应的变化
所以这些呢大家还是以我们开源仓的 README的信息为准
再后面就是我们需要安装我们的torch
这里面需要安装两个
主要就是原版的torch
还有就是我们昇腾的torch插件
就是torch_npu
两个的版本都是2.6.0
然后我们就可以安装我们的torch_npu
这里面呢我们提供了一个pip的安装命令
大家通过这个方式就可以拿到我们最新的torch_npu
的版本
不过我们现在的torch_npu呢是基于社区的3.2的版本来构建的
所以在后面呢我们的torch_npu也会跟上社区的新版本发布
所以说呢这个pip的安装版本的命令也会发生变化
大家还是关注我们的开源仓
再往后我们就可以运行我们的算子实例了
因为torch_npu本身呢它是一个jit编译的方式
也就是说它不会像我们的c或C++一样
需要我们先通过算子工程去完成算子的构建
然后再去调用我们的算子
这边呢我们就可以直接通过python来跑我们的算子脚本
在脚本里呢我们写了算子的实现函数
还有调用的函数
然后呢我们就相当于说执行这一行命令
就可以把我们的算子从编译构建到运行全部完成
然后CANN包呢在前两页呢我们给大家点出了我们的下载位置
还有文档的位置
但是如果大家懒得看的话
尤其是在安装命令上懒得看的话
大家就可以用下边的这两条命令来完成CANN的安装
这里面呢我们主要就是设置好我们CANN的安装路径
还有呢就是install选项
就可以完成我们的两个版本的安装
然后quiet呢可以给大家省掉很多显示出来的信息
Triton Ascend的第二种安装方式就是通过源码来构建
这种方式就适用于那些对编译领域比较感兴趣
想对我们的Triton Ascend进行一些创新或者扩展优化
或者一些扩展功能的朋友们
整体流程上呢大概分为三步
第一步就是安装我们的依赖
包括系统库依赖
还有python库依赖
然后呢就是对于指定的某个LLLVM版本
去构建好LLLVM的代码
这里呢我们可以选择通过clang构建
或者是通过gcc来构建
第三步呢就是构建我们的Triton Ascend了
在这里呢有两个需求
一个是clang还有ld
这两个工具的版本必须要在15以上
如果我们的环境呢因为一些原因
不能安装这两个比较高的版本的话
后边也有绕过的方式
因为呢整体的源码构建流程呢相对来说
需要的时间比较长
步骤也比较繁琐
所以后面呢我们其实也会给大家来做一个镜像
来简化源码构建的流程
现在在开源仓呢大家已经可以看到了一个Dockerfile
在后续的话我们其实也会在网上去上线一些
已经构建好的镜像
来供大家直接拉取使用
但在这里呢我们还是先把整体的一个安装流程给大家过一遍
首先第一步就是安装我们的依赖
这里呢我们有一些系统工具的要求
GCC在9.4.0以上
然后cmake在3.27以上
然后还有我们的一些软件包版本
比如说Python的版本
还有说torch和torch_npu的版本
那我们系统工具的依赖呢就是下面这三个
当然这里要注意一下
用文档示例里呢是用apt install
来装的这个zlib1g
但是这个在YUM安装的话呢是叫另一个名字
所以大家可以根据这些系统来区分一下
然后呢下面呢就是一个两个例子
就以Ubuntu这个系统为例
我们安装呢
首先是这个就这些apt install
就可以把我们这几个系统库的依赖给装好
然后ccache这个是选择啊
然后这个如果安装的话
可以对就是我们后边的LLLVM
还有triton-ascend的构建
还有一个选项
但这个是不是强制的
但这三个是强制的
然后另外就是我们的这个Python安装
然后也是这个在我们的README里边
大家可以看到有需要的这些库
还有他们指定版本
这些版本其实是和前面这个Python的版本
是基本上是一致的
所以大家可以在我们的那个开源舱上
直接复制这个命令
然后下来来安装
然后下一步就是构建安装LLLVM
LLLVM其实就是这个一个编译器的一个部分
然后它呢因为我们triton-ascend
其实是基于MLIR的
这样的话呢
MLIR这个社区呢
现在已经融合在LLLVM社区里边了
所以我们需要在这个
用我们的指定版本
来对它进行一个构建
当然第一步还是
直接git clone
然后把这个开源舱下载下来
然后呢我们这里边要checkout
这个我们特定的一个commit
然后在下面的具体构建呢
就是我们分为两种
一种是clone构建
一种GCC构建
然后都是说我们先指定我们的一个安装路径
然后下面就我们的这个命令来构建
那这一边呢我们在enable projects里边
一定要选择MLIR、LLLVM还有LLD
然后像我们之前提到过
上一章提过我们这个系统库的版本
当然有的这个clang15
还有lld15的依赖
但是如果说呢我们的
比如说实际上这个电脑的一些情况
可能装不了这两个版本
那这样的话呢
我们就有个方法
就是在我们用GCC构建的时候呢
我们把这个clang和lld
给加到这个enable projects里边
然后这样呢
它构建的时候
就是一起把这两个工具也给构建出来
当然只是最后
我们在完成安装之后
我们要注意说
把这个我们安装路径的那个
bin目录给加到那个path里边
这样才能让后边
我们triton-ascend的构建的时候
能找到这两个工具
然后我们如果编的时候
出现这个链接错误
我们可以在这个第二个步骤里边
再设置这个enable lld
这个设置为on
当然如果说先提到我们系统库上
有个可选项的这个ccache
这个ccache如果已经安装
而且功能正常的话
我们就可以再加入这个ccache build
去加速这个构建
但如果没装的话
就不要开了
然后最后一步就是安装我们这个triton-ascend的
这个其实我们开源仓安装
其实都这个路径嘛
第一步都是说先把我们这个开源仓代码给下下来
然后呢就是确认我们LLLVM的这个安装路径
也就是上一步我们指定的那个路径
然后再确认一下我们已经有clang和lld这两个版本
ccache还是看你自己实际情况
然后我们就可以用下边这一套
这个命令
安装我们triton-ascend
这个进行之后呢
现在就说它会
一个是自动给我们这个triton-ascend构建出无有包
然后再把它给安装到我们当前的这个python环境里边
这边要注意呢
我们gc呢
如果说不到9.4
那就也会可能报这样的一个错
这就说明其实链接呢
找不到stdc++fs这个库
那这个库呢它主要是用来这个支持gcc9之前版本的文件系统特性
所以这样的话
那如果出现这个问题
我们就需要手动的把CMakeLists文件
这个相关的这个片段的注释来打开
就是这一块
给这个注释打开之后再重新构建这个项目
就可以解决这个问题
然后这样安装好之后
其实相当于说我们triton-ascend就已经安装完成了
然后我们就可以来运行我们的用例
但是之前我也讲过我们运行用例的时候
它是需要给予我们的CAN来运行的
但这就需要我们还是不能往这一步
就是我们要把那个环境变量的脚本给source一下
把那些环境变量给配好才能用好我们的CAN
所以说配置好环境变量之后
大家就可以直接用这个Python
运行这个脚本的方式
就可以把运行我们的这个Triton算子
然后算子的用例
其实大家都可以在我们这个example里边去找到
然后大家可以在这个example里边去找到